نعم بالفعل هذا اليوم اعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن مقتل جندي اخر في هذه
المعارك المتواصله وقال بان هذا الجندي
قتل في معارك جنوب غزه يوم امس ليضاف
الى العدد الكبير عمليا لجنود وضباط الجيش
الاسرائيلي الذين قتلوا منذ بدايه الحرب
وتحديدا منذ بدايه العمليه البريه في غزه
في ال 26 من الشهر الجاري اكثر من 200
جنديا قتلوا في العمليات البريه وهو
بطبيعه الحال عدد كبير قياسا بما كان
يتوقعه ربما الجيش الاسرائيلي مع بدايه
هذه الحرب هذا بالاضافه الى اعداد
الاصابات الكبيره جدا الجيش الاسرائيلي
يتحدث عن عدد من الاصابات لم يتجاوز 3000
منذ بدايه هذه الحرب تحديدا يتحدث عن 2800
ولكن هذا العدد تحديدا تتحدث عنه
المستشفيات على نحو اكبر بكثير يعني كل
مستشفى من ابرز المستشفيات التي تعاملت
وقدمت العلاج للجنود الذين اصيبوا في هذه
المعارك تتحدث عن اعداد اكبر كل مستشفى
تعاملت مع عدد اكبر من العدد الذي يتحدث
عنه الجيش
بالمجمل والحديث ايضا يدور عن اصابات غايه
في الخطوره كانت قد نشرت عنها وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه ابرزها قضيه اي الب في الاطراف
وفي ال ايضا في الاعين عما كامل في الاعين
وهم يصبحون من فئه معاقي الجيش الاسرائيلي
ويتلقون علاجات متواصله ضمن تاهيل تقدمه
وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه والحديث عن الاف
سلمى وفقا لما نشر في وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه اذا هي خسائر كبيره بالاضافه
ايضا الى ما ما نشر في وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه خلال الايام الاخيره الماضيه
عن الاصابات على المستوى النفسي ايضا وان
هناك الاف الجنود والضباط لجوا لطلب علاج
ودعم نفسي بعد مكوثهم في غزه خلال
العمليات ال البريه الجيش يتحدث عن 3000
توجهوا لقسم الدعم النفسي التابع للجيش
بينما تتحدث وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه عن
اكثر من 9000 جندي وضابط وا يوم امس كان
هناك مقال مطول بهذا الصدد في دعو احرونوت
يتحدث عن عوارض خطيره جدا اي يعاني منها
الجنود الذين يعودون من ارض المعركه منها
حاله ال القلق وحاله الصدمه وقله النوم
وما يخشى منه الجيش هو ان تؤثر مثل هذه
الحالات النفسيه على ادائهم في داخل
المعركه لان جزء منهم يتلقى دعم نفسي
ويعود الى ارض ال المعركه من جهه اخرى
اخرى سلمى هذا اليوم هناك اجتماع في ساعات
المساء بين مسؤولين من وزارات مختلفه في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وبين رؤساء المجالس
المحليه لبلدات غلاف غزه بحسب التسريبات
فان هناك اطار بدات تضعه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بشان اعاده سكان منطقه الغلاف
والحديث يدور عم من يسكنون في بلدات تبعد
من اربعه الى سبعه كيلومترات عن ال حدود
مع غزه بعد ان اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي او
الجبهه الداخليه تحديدا التابعه للجيش
الاسرائيلي في الايام الاخيره الماضيه عن
بدء ازاله جزء من القيود المفروضه على
تجمع السكان في هذه المناطق لكن هذا يقابل
برفض كبير من السكان هذه المناطق الذين
يخشون العوده في هذه المرحله قبل ان تنتهي
الحرب وقبل ان تحسم هذه الحرب وقبل ان
تتوقف اطلاق الصواريخ اي سلمى وفقط دعيني
اش انه خلال هذه المداخله كان هناك قصف
مدفعي استهدف عده مواقع شمال قطاع غزه
شكرا لك من غلاف غزه مراسلتنا نجوان
سمري